digamos que tenemos una función f de x
igual a menos 4 por la raíz cúbica raíz
cúbica de x ahora lo que nosotros
queremos es encontrar cuánto vale la
derivada de esa función
efe
8 ponle pausa a este vídeo y observa si
puedes resolverlo por tu cuenta
bueno es posible que esto te parezca un
poco extraño al principio pero como
vamos a ver aquí podemos aplicar la
regla de las potencias porque esta
función también se puede describir así
efe de x es igual a menos 4 por equis
elevada a la potencia un tercio y ahora
si ya queda un poco más claro que
podemos aplicar la regla de las
potencias podemos tomar este exponente
un tercio y multiplicarlo por el
coeficiente menos 4 y nos queda menos 4
por un tercio y luego multiplicamos por
equis pero elevada a la un tercio menos
1 y esta es la derivada de la función
efe es f prima de x y sólo nos falta
simplificarlo y nos queda como
menos cuatro tercios por equis elevada a
la potencia un tercio menos uno pero un
tercio menos uno son menos dos tercios y
si queremos evaluar a efe prima en ocho
nos queda menos cuatro tercios por ocho
elevada a la menos dos tercios pero esto
también es igual al menos cuatro tercios
por ocho elevado a la un tercio y todo
esto elevado a la menos 2 aquí lo único
que estoy haciendo es utilizar las
propiedades de los exponentes si te
parece un poco extraño y no sabes muy
bien cómo pasamos de aquí para acá te
recomiendo que veas nuestros vídeos de
las propiedades de los exponentes aquí
en kant academy
8 elevado a la un tercio es 2 entonces
tenemos que elevar 2 a la potencia menos
2 y aquí si lo vamos a hacer paso por
paso es una muy buena práctica esto es
igual a menos cuatro tercios por 2
elevado a la menos 202 elevado a la
menos 2 es igual a 1 entre 2 elevado a
la 2 estas dos expresiones son
exactamente iguales 2 elevado a la menos
2 es igual a 1 entre 2 elevado a la 2
pero dos elevado a la 2 es igual a 4 y
estos dos se van a cancelar por lo que
esto nos queda igual a menos un tercio
menos uno entre 3
ya terminamos